we're ready to go now sorry for the
delay so just to remind you what we're
thinking of here is what happens if you
know what f of X looks like so here's a
straight line it's the same one we had a
look at yesterday twice if this is what
f of X looks like then what does the
square root of f of X look like you
might like to jot that down on your left
hand side so you know we're thinking
about okay now the first thing I'm going
to ask you about is this part we've
shaded in red this is the original f of
X and it's below the x-axis why do you
think that might be an important part to
look at what can you tell me about this
part down here Astin yeah this this part
of a graph right when you try and take
the square root of it you're not going
to get anything sensible out about that
on the Cartesian plane anyway so this
whole section here I can now ignore
right I've said I'm not gonna get
anything useful out of that so great
this is some work I don't have to do ok
then we also graphed y equals 1 why do
you think y equals 1 might be important
when we're thinking about square roots
what's the square root of one it's one
so anywhere that our original function
intersects with y equals one like say
right there okay when you take the
square root of that you're also going to
get or sorry that should be across
you're also gonna get one square root of
one is one think back to all of the
graphs and transformations we did in the
last few lessons what are the values for
this function are important not just one
the x-intercept is very important for y
equals zero which is just there right
why is that significant what's the
square root of zero zero okay now for
reasons then we come clear in a second
so now I've got crosses here I'm going
to do or three more crosses over here
I'm gonna ask you to draw this guy here
instead of a cross draw a nice big fat
dot I'll explain in a little bit or
maybe you can explain in a little bit
why I'm putting a fat dot there rather
than just an X like I usually do okay so
I've got um I've got an X there I'm
looking now for I've got these like all
of the points that are usually important
I'm now looking for any values that are
on the graph which I know I can take the
square root of and get a nice number out
right so you can see for right up the
top
right can you look what's the x value
that corresponds to y k-- was fall it's
six very good so over at x equals six y
is equal to four so when I take the
square root of that I will get two which
should be right there so go ahead put
next day okay if you want it you kind of
could go in between so for example I
happen to know that the square root of
two there's two there the square root of
two is about 1.4 you can go check that
into your calculator and get something
out of that so if that's two then when I
take the square root of this Y value I
should go down I think one point four
would be about that's one isn't it so
one point four is back here just below
that extra line so go ahead let's put
another cross in okay so you can kind of
see there's a shape happening over here
we can join up these dots predictably
before we do that there's one more cross
I'm gonna put it I'm gonna cheat by
zooming in which I know you can't do but
do you remember I'm actually going to go
back to you because I think I have it on
this particular thing when we were
squaring well this one do yeah this is a
good one okay so when we were this is
when we were squaring functions okay now
I want you to look and see if you can
tell this is again is the Weick was one
line okay so what Y value does this look
like here that's one this is like this
is just a half right it's halfway up to
one and then do you notice what point
did I plot when I was squaring because
you do a half you square it what do you
get a quarter like that right when
you're squaring a half becomes a quarter
so right now I'm taking square roots so
I should go in the opposite direction
right if I can find a quarter let's have
a look at the graph we look at now if I
can find a quarter on here the square
root of 1/4 is 1/2 right where's 1/4 on
this can you look and find it
it's pretty close in right so if this is
one that makes this a half that makes
this yes I think this is a quarter do
you see that I know you've got to like
put your face right up to the page but
there he is so there's a quarter what's
the square root of a quarter it's a half
so I'm gonna put an X just above there
okay whoops that's highlighting sorry
there you go okay now I think we can
join this together you could put in a
few more points if you are confident but
I'm pretty sure this is staying to look
like this kind of shape like so what do
you think of that are you happy with
that like I've joined up the dots you
can see they're steeper earlier on and
then it kind of like shallows out over
here now hopefully when you look at this
this shouldn't be too much of a surprise
for you right because we have actually
dealt with functions like this before
sorry this is not reciprocal functions I
was just shading and usually the same
page so just gonna get rid of that there
we go this graph here can someone tell
me what the equation in this graph is y
equals it's a straight line
I'm gonna give you could start to the
next X minus 2 right so what we've just
done that's f of X the square root of
that is y equals the square root of x
minus 2 and we've dealt with this before
it's half of a sideways parabola yeah
it's just the positive half why don't I
have the other side down here yeah yeah
see this square root here right it can
only be the positive part okay so that's
what the shape is remember we're looking
for the same important values we were
before zero one very important any other
numbers like for which we can easily
take the square root off and then
anything that's underneath the axis we
just said forget about it can't a square
root so don't worry about it I want you
to try this guy on for size this is x
squared plus 5x plus 6 just like you've
seen many times I want you to look for
those important points maybe you want to
draw it in y equals 1 and then look for
some values that you can also work out
have a go give you a few minutes if you
think you've got an idea course over